bitcoin and cryptocurrencies is a brand
new industry we're watching the
technologists the entrepreneurs and
innovators build it in real time at the
same exact time investors are pouring
literally billions of dollars into the
industry trying to fuel economic
prosperity job creation and ultimately
innovation at the same exact time that
the industry is trying to build this in
real time the regulators are trying to
figure out what should the rules be do
the old rules apply or should there be
brand new rules as part of that process
the regulators are trying to learn right
alongside the entrepreneurs and
investors but now there's some concerns
coming from some of the politicians in
america they're saying that that request
to learn trying to gather information is
becoming burdensome to the actual
companies and entrepreneurs who are
trying to build the industry recently
there was a tweet from representative
tom emmer what he said was that my
office has received numerous tips from
crypto and blockchain firms that sec
chair gary ginsler's information
reporting request to the crypto
community or over burdensome don't feel
particularly voluntarily and are
stifling innovation so representative
emmer came together with a group of
bipartisan politicians and they've
actually put forward a letter to the sec
chair regarding the sec's crypto
information seeking process and emer
went on to say that while the sec has
authority to obtain information from
market participants for rulemaking
purposes it must ensure that the
inquiries don't infringe on various
standards and that they don't actually
become burdensome because the government
imposes on private businesses or
citizens lastly he believes that crypto
startups must not be weighed down by
extra jurisdictional and burdensome
reporting requirements we will ensure
our regulators do not kill american
innovation and innovation opportunities
ultimately this is probably the right
way to approach it we understand that
regulators need to have information
they're learning just as the
entrepreneurs and investors are as well
but there's got to be a balance between
the information seeking and the ability
for these companies and entrepreneurs to
build the industry this is a race the
united states wants to be a leader we
have the president's executive order
stating that we want to be a leader in
bitcoin of cryptocurrencies ultimately
rules are good clarity are good but also
speed and innovation is just as
important hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time